il doit 10h30 presque sept heures ont
fini les préparations je me jette à
l'eau grande aventure j'ai une idée de
ce qui va se passer mais ça va être
fantastique
nous rejoignons l'expédition à 15 heures
l'équipe a déjà cinq heures de retard à
bord la tension est au maximum
la plongeuse a perdu une vis à sa
combinaison qui n'est plus étanche
oui on il veut tout de suite sans croix
blanche
des plongeurs des secouristes et des
médecins
en tout une trentaine de bénévoles
s'assure que l'expédition se déroule
bien il faut veiller sur les équipements
et sur la plongeuse la personne qui sort
en oeuvre d'autres un premier plongeur
apporte la pièce manquante un second
apport à la nourriture sociétaux et
avocats du chocolat et il faut aussi
changer les batteries du système de
communication et du gps comme nous
l'avons fait benoît qui tu récupères
avec aaron parce qu'on a eu pendant
pendant qu'ils plongent à 13 pieds sa
coéquipière notre tou et prépare le
prochain défi les rapides de lachine
j'espérais qu'il y arrivera les rêves
soyons réalistes s'est passé même si
elle est deux fois plus vite
il répond nathalie est le moral est bon
à minuit nathalie lasselin rejoint
l'équipage
mais décidément c'est pas la première
fois que je mesure au fleuve saint
laurent et il n méchante tendance à
toujours gagner sur moi en tout cas au
départ l'exploratrice n'a pas dit son
dernier mot
elle a vaincu des rapides de lachine les
bras en continu
en ligne continue une odyssée un exploit
mais aussi une expédition à caractère
scientifique puisque des échantillons du
fleuve seront prélevés et analysés